merci heureuse chère Clara comme
tu m'as manqué tu sais qu'il ne se passe pas un jour où tu
ne me manques pas profondément jamais je ne me suis senti
plus vivant que lorsque tu me regardais j'ai
eu une vraie douleur au cœur j'ai besoin d'
argent je te donne un  prêt si vous en avez besoin
sachez juste comment trouver votre argent je suis juste
venu voir mon fils Oh Fanny je suis désolé je
ne voulais pas te faire peur hier soir
j'aimerais monter dans mon bateau j'ai un livre avec
fanny
monter sur l'océan il vient de disparaître que
ferais-je sans mon ami autour de vous
savez que je serais triste le vendredi
ces gens de ma vie debout ici
ils attendent un miracle mais peut-être que
cette autre femme reviendra peut-
être et peut-être  vous vous souviendrez comment aimer
quelqu'un avec plus qu'un animal vous
ne savez pas qui je suis
mais aucun d'eux ne signifie quelque chose pour moi je suis
désolé, moquons-nous de moi,
nous serions formidables si vous pouviez être un  père
non ton cul sur la photo oui pourquoi
détestes-tu tout le monde
tu sais que le ballon appartient au ciel d'
où il vient oh ça devient solitaire
je t'aime beaucoup  beaucoup à la semaine prochaine